[Music]
anybody ever uh thought of uh or needed
to be in a situation where you'd be like
let me donate this organ to this person
in order to save their lives hell no
real quick well how many organs can you
actually donate what does she look like
being in a democracy
do you guys have anyone that important
in your lives right now where you feel
like i would give somebody something
away because i get it like maybe taika
or like if you have a kid right i mean
other than family
you mean a non-blood related non-blood
like i get it relationship maybe a wife
or whatever but like i don't know it's
tough yeah
like if ryan hit me up he's like dude i
need your kidney
i would seriously consider it but i
don't know if it's an automatic and i'm
like the doctor said it can only be
anthony's kidney yeah yeah if it's a
situation like that i think yeah that
that's easier to be like okay that's
cool like you feel compelled to yeah
you're called to it but if you're like i
want your kidney walter i think it
depends how i ask too
like i i i i qualify for 20 different
kidneys but i want yours and it's like a
title tone that i shouldn't get the
kidney yeah i'm like sorry
or if you propose it to the whole room
and you're like i need any one of your
guys kidneys everyone's just going to
sit there and wait for someone else to
raise and is someone dying though is it
like either
everybody's alive you just need to
switch organs have mild discomfort just
for fun
i get tummy aches sometimes but it eats
too fast
i either ask you
hey i'm gonna die anthony wear a match i
need your kidney or whatever right i
think that's different than um i don't
really need your kidney i could also
have this machine that i walk around
with
you know
is it a drama
does the machine look like anthony
because it's a convenient anthony can
you buy me this machine or give me a
kidney yeah
with kendra's money yeah would you
rather buy this machine or would you
give me a kidney irony actually in this
situation is this man
receives a huge medical bill after
donating his own kidneys
in the states is it the u.s it's in the
u.s [ __ ]
they couldn't cover it what the other
yes caveat for [ __ ] donating kidneys
he didn't get full coverage i thought
the donation stuff was everyone else
takes care of it yeah don't think it's a
free pass
you gotta donate your money too like so
hey so if i die and they take the organs
out of my body because my parents have
to pay for it it goes to my family the
bill goes to my family because you get a
service fee
that's that's not supposed to be okay
let me tell you about services twenty
percent
cause i went to the super bowl i don't
know if you guys know this ruble
wait so how does this work and what part
did he had to give away so it was his
kidney uh this guy's name is elliott
malin was contacted by the mother of his
cousin 28 year old scott klein so his
aunt and a
[Laughter]
in order to find a donor match as he was
in end-stage renal failure
uh malin and klein consider themselves
cousins although their blood
relationship is more distant than that
she contacted as many people as possible
like our scenario earlier uh in in the
hope of finding a donor to help her son
and meline kindly agreed wait so they're
they're also distant relatives distant
cousins yeah so it might as well be a
stranger yeah for real blood wise i
think klein wasn't yet on dialysis but
he was going to need the operation the
subject line of the email stated scott
needs a kidney it continued thank you
for considering it but please don't feel
it's a spam pressure to do it
sorry i have to share this bird in but
the best potential match is family so
maybe there is i'm gonna report that as
spam dude
and be like i never saw it i'm a word
what email spam and i'm a block [ __ ]
email
so
malin who lives in nevada us didn't need
to think too hard about it and decided
that he'd help klein that's what you get
for being a good person dude you get hit
with the bill nevadans dude they never
make the right decisions
it's not clear what happened to clients
kidneys but he needed help and needed it
badly four months after mellon signed up
it became clear he was a match the
amount of hoops you have to jump through
to do this is pretty extraordinary the
hospital was amazing on trying to help
everything as easy as possible
and in july last year the surgery was
performed at baylor scott and white all
saints medical center in fort worth
texas
now whilst he realized that the
operation of subsequent recovery would
be tough he didn't expect to receive any
kind of bill for his generosity what is
it [ __ ] like 100 g's or some [ __ ] it
wasn't a living donors who give their
organs to others are not supposed to be
billed for any medical expenses as the
recipient's insurance covers it if
they're not insured the tab is usually
picked up by medicare however due to a
billing mistake
mallon received the bill for a
staggering thirteen thousand sixty four
dollars from north star a company that
provides anesthesia including baylor
scott and white all saints
what's more is they threatened that the
bill might go to collections if unpaid
oh my
who would have thought giving your
kidney would cost an arm and a leg
who has the lamest jokes in here
just cross me man
somehow anthony gets the [ __ ] out of the
stick like that's an attack on him
i am not buying your liver machine or
whatever the [ __ ] you want oh yeah you
just gotta die dude you just burned your
bridge robo
the guy that walks around by the time
you need the kidney machine they'll make
it so small that you could put it in
your sex robot so you always could take
your sexual at least
oh
hey why do you have that thing you're
perv no this helps me survive yeah
that's my dialysis my liver for me
that's true you know what's going on
[ __ ] sketchy when you donate blood
right
it's free
i love this
when you shoot up heroin
it's free yeah that's free right here
nurse lady it's ice in my veins this is
different oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay where do you do the three we donate
blood right
it's it's free
and you could donate [ __ ] i don't
know how many liters right for your your
lifetime 35 35 okay 35. but when you
need blood
in this in the operation you still got
to pay for it there's no [ __ ] way
it's like a thrift store bro
you get to drop off [ __ ] at goodwill but
you still got to buy it yeah they should
give you credit that if you need an
operation you should be able to get
pints of blood you know what that would
actually be a good idea because it would
it would actually make people donate
more blood don't you get paid for
donating blood no you get a sticker and
a [ __ ] high school you you get so i
donated some blood uh
like last year and then after they
donate blood they they send your email
and they tell you like hey you actually
helped this person during that it's cool
and it low-key got me kind of like they
send you a picture no they don't send
you a picture but they they tell you
like you helped that your blood actually
went to someone who had something like
this or whatever that's dope and it
actually kind of got me like choked up a
little bit bro i was like yeah what if
and i never donate blood again
but what if that person i've been
meaning to go back to
i got emails from the company and
they're like we're a blood shortage i'm
like i already did my part that's all
right i want a [ __ ] shout out video
of the guy getting the blood going
thanks bro oh it feels so good but what
if that guy dies later on like blood
infection i'm like i gotta [ __ ] the
blood so can you take the blood back if
they end up being a criminal
yes you can i think i should be like you
helped this guy survive and then now he
went to rob five liquor stores
you gotta go get it yourself you slit
this don't wanna get a bullet
give it back to me [ __ ] you
gotta drink it
[ __ ] you
your blood was used for a drug offender
who later got his throat sliced by
parker
yeah
pretty complex but he's getting his
blood back so double jeopardy it's all
good damn that's would you guys
ask like if someone if if someone was
like yo i need a new [ __ ] liver or
whatever right my first question to them
would be like
what did you do yeah because if it's
like if it's like oh
i got kiss uh because of like because
genetics and it's like all right i'll
help you out right but if it's like i
drank too much beer it's like [ __ ] you
die [ __ ] yeah for real that's on you
and i i wish we knew why this guy's
coors should give him a free flight yeah
tell coors yeah
they should take the tab on them so the
first one see because i'm nicer than joe
the first time i i'll give a sliver of
liver
that's how that's how it works liver
donations that's how it works because it
grows yeah they take a sliver of it yeah
but if they came back
and was it's the same problem then it's
like yo no you squandered my sliver my
good liver
and yeah so now you can't even get it
back though because i ruined it no but
but
but my no would be very like emphatic
and emotionally powerful for me and
cathartic like very like stern and very
like wow
[Laughter]
to make them feel like oh man shouldn't
have asked him you showed him yeah you
know i like that though but
because you have hope where you're like
maybe
they'll change their way maybe yeah
maybe they learn their lesson they're
like thank you and then you guys can go
grab beers afterwards right yes but then
probably not beers
like kool-aid or something yeah but if
they you know regress and then they get
like you know they have a heavy drinking
problem again yo man hey remember like
last time can you hook me up uh knob
like last time
you came through with the liver dude it
came through
did that thing for me
it was like yo we got another we gonna
do it all over again
wasn't that such a good time
remember we were in the hospital for
three days when your thing regenerated
and it was like totally fine
and remember we're on the operating
table and we kind of reached out and
like high five each other that i feel so
bonded with you well let's do it all
again
i would say that i'm very
stingy with my body parts but i i but if
a friend's like yo man
like i need help and i'll be like all
right let me i'll just mortgage my house
for you i mean i'll i'll refile whatever
i'll i'll give you all the [ __ ] money
in my bank account yeah but it's like
hey joe i need help man i know you do
[Laughter]
but if it's like hey i need a hand and
i'm like
no you don't
i just needed to move this couch it's
like nah nah you don't need no [ __ ]
i'm just kidding it's like it's like i'm
not gonna give him [ __ ] like oh i need
can i get like one of those eyeballs you
have two and i'm like nah nah bro even
if it's my kid i'm like man [ __ ] you
dude it i could make another one like
why
take your future brother's
eyes don't take mine
so joe has a baby to give that contact i
[ __ ] clone this fool and then just be
like 3d over the same dna yeah easy just
to end with some actual news just so
it's a slightly happier ending this was
all actual news
well otherwise we could have just left
it and said that north star uh just
claimed collections but
there was obviously dispute uh after
initially dismissing the bills following
the surgery they actually became more
threatening and even included references
to delinquent payments and further
collection
however they eventually came around the
table and the bill was sorted their cfo
kate said said an email to milan on
behalf of north star i apologize for
causing any confusion or concern
regarding this matter and assure you
that it has been resolved so he's all
good now give him a kidney then give him
a kidney give him another thing for pain
and suffering from the harassment yeah
uh yeah it says it says they gave him a
joke elections and [ __ ] oh yeah i don't
know how that [ __ ] works i had a [ __ ]
refi my house for these [ __ ]
you